Everybody's favorite friendly neighborhood
Spider-Man is set to swing back into theaters
come July 2019.
And while audiences everywhere are all set
for another Spidey-fest, Marvel Studios sure
is taking its time doling out the details.
For now, we'll have to settle for these previously
leaked tidbits and the ever reliable rumor
mill.
Here's what we know, or think we know, so
far.
In January 2019, we learned that Nick Fury
won't be the only S.H.I.E.L.D.
veteran returning to the MCU in Spider-Man:
Far from Home.
"So nice to finally meet you, Spider-Man."
"You're Nick Fury."
The first Far from Home teaser trailer contained
a brief shot that showed a pair of characters
who seemed to be former S.H.I.E.L.D.
Agent Maria Hill and Nick Fury being attacked
by an Elemental, but fans were not entirely
sure... until actress Cobie Smulders set the
record straight.
She posted a screenshot of herself and Samuel
L. Jackson on Instagram, writing in the photo's
caption:
"It's me!
It's me!
I swear...
[The] one on the left… no not the monster…
the one with the ponytail."
Obviously, Smulders was joking about anyone
confusing her with what appears to be a massive
sand creature, though ironically the last
time we saw Smulders as Maria Hill was in
Avengers: Infinity War's post-credits scene
when Hill and her old boss Fury were both
"dusted" by Thanos' decimation.
So… maybe she wasn't joking.
Throughout 2017's Spider-Man: Homecoming,
every attempt by Peter Parker to contact Tony
Stark or the Avengers was filtered through
Stark's pal Happy Hogan, portrayed by MCU
veteran Jon Favreau.
We missed out on seeing Happy in Avengers:
Infinity War, so there was some question as
to whether or not the guy whose favorite pastime
was ignoring Peter Parker would be around
for Far from Home.
"This is you."
"Oh, we're neighbors?"
"We're not roommates.
Suit up."
"Okay, Peter, you got this, you got this."
"What the hell are you wearing?"
We got our first inkling that Happy was returning
in September 2018, when a Reddit user posted
a video that appeared to show Favreau on the
set of Far from Home.
The return of Happy was finally confirmed
in January 2019 with the release of the first
Spider-Man: Far from Home teaser trailer,
which featured, among other things, Happy
getting flirty with Aunt May.
"You look nice."
"Thank you!
You too."
"Thank you.
New dress?"
"Yes, it is.
How'd you know?"
"What just happened?"
It will be interesting to see how, if at all,
Happy's new interest in Parker's aunt will
affect the way he treats the young hero.
We doubt it.
September 2018 was a big month for rumors
and spoilers for Spider-Man: Far from Home,
but not all of them were accurate.
Along with the set video that leaked Jon Favreau,
it was the month SuperBroMovies reported that
Gwyneth Paltrow would appear in Far from Home
as Pepper Potts.
While Robert Downey Jr. and Jon Favreau had
larger roles in Spider-Man: Homecoming, Paltrow
appeared briefly in the film's final moments
for the Spider-Man press conference that never
happened.
"Did you guys screw this up?"
"He told the kid to go wait in the car."
"Are you kidding me?
I have a room full of people in there waiting
for some big announcement.
What am I gonna tell them?"
We've since heard that the rumor of Pepper's
return in July's Far From Home was a false
one.
In February 2019, Paltrow told Variety that
April's Avengers: Endgame will be her last
film as part of the MCU, at least for the
near future.
Paltrow told Variety:
"I mean, I'm a bit old to be in a suit and
all that at this point."
But she didn't discount a brief return in
the future.
Paltrow went on to say, quote, "Of course,
if they said, 'Can you come back for a day?,'
I will always be there if they need me."
The tragic Gwen Stacy, the girl Peter Parker
loved but couldn't save, was played by Bryce
Dallas Howard in 2007's Spider-Man 3.
Next, Emma Stone took the role for the two
Andrew Garfield Spidey films.
With everything already going on in Spider-Man:
Far from Home, it doesn't necessarily seem
like the ideal fit for her introduction.
But ideal fit or not, in December 2017 a number
of supposed audition tapes surfaced with different
actresses claiming to be vying for the part
of Gwen Stacy in the next Spider-Man movie.
Iris Haller, whose only credited work is for
a German soap opera, is one of the apparent
hopefuls.
Another auditioning actress introduces herself
only as "Luna" and speaks with what appears
to be a thick French accent.
Since the tapes were leaked, there's been
no word on Gwen Stacy appearing in Far from
Home.
Maybe the recordings were intentional red
herrings, maybe they were fakes, but time
will tell for sure.
Early in November 2018, Marvel launched a
clock counting down the 240 days until the
July 2019 release of Spider-Man: Far from
Home.
That specific number has some fans claiming
that Miles Morales, the version of Spider-Man
featured in 2018's Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse,
could be appearing in Far from Home.
"C'mon dude, let's go.
Miles!"
Why is the number 240 significant, you ask?
It just so happens that acclaimed writer and
Miles Morales creator Brian Michael Bendis
ended his tenure with Marvel's Spider-Man
with issue #240 in May 2018.
That's all it took to get fans speculating
whether there was a connection between the
two numbers.
That's not much of a confirmation that Morales
will be in Far from Home.
It could just be a coincidence, after all.
On the other hand, considering the undeniable
success of Spider-Man: Into the Spider-Verse
as well as the fact that a deleted Spider-Man:
Homecoming scene mentioned a character Miles
by name…
"Yeah, sorry, Miles.
I'm...
I'm not gonna make it.
Yeah, I'm just stuck."
… the notion of Morales appearing alongside
Tom Holland's Peter Parker may be less a question
of if than a question of when.
In August 2018, The Wrap reported that Crazy
Rich Asians actor Remy Hii had been cast in
Spider-Man: Far from Home… as, well, someone.
Nobody seems to be entirely sure who yet.
Just about every noteworthy Spider-Man bad
guy has been rumored to be appearing in Spider-Man:
Far from Home at one point or another.
So, with the exception of Vulture or Mysterio,
Hii could be portraying just about any of
them.
On the other hand; the Australian actor's
Chinese ancestry, the martial arts training
he received for his role in Netflix's Marco
Polo, Far from Home's international scope,
and reports of Marvel developing a film for
Shang-Chi have all fed speculation that Spider-Man:
Far from Home could see Remy Hii bringing
that character to the MCU.
On the other, more plausible hand, Shang-Chi
probably isn't included in Sony's Marvel character
deal, so Marvel Studios might not debut an
upcoming franchise character in a Sony co-production.
But maybe Hii could be playing Martin Li,
also known as the popular Spider-Man villain
Mister Negative.
While Far From Home already seems stuffed
with villains, this film could be setting
up the Martin Li character, who's a family
friend to Peter and May, so he can go dark
in a future movie.
Check out one of our newest videos right here!
Plus, even more Looper videos about your favorite
stuff are coming soon.
Subscribe to our YouTube channel and hit the
bell so you don't miss a single one.